وبالتوازي مع التطورات الميدانيه يستمر
القصف الاسرائيلي على مناطق متفرقه من
القطاع مسفرا عن سقوط شهداء وجرحى في
الاثناء اعلنت بلديه غزه انهيار منظومه
خدماتها بسبب استمرار العدوان وانقطاع
الوقود بشكل تام من جهته قال مدير وكاله
الاونور وفي غزه ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يامر
سكان غزه بالانتقال للمناطق التي تتعرضوا
لغارات مستمره معنا من مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى في دير البلح مراسل الجزيره هشام
زقوت هشام اذا تطورات ميدانيه متسارعه في
ظل دعوات قوات الاحتلال لان يتوجه سكان
غزه لمناطق تقصف من جديد ما الذي
رصدته بالفعل هو قصف اسرائيلي مستمر
ومتواصل مناطق عده تعرضت الى قصف عنيف من
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه وايضا شنت الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه سلسله من الغ على
مناطق مختلفه من القطاع من شرق مدينه رفح
وحتى جباليه شمال القطاع تعرضت عده مناطق
الى قصف من الطائرات وايضا المدفعيه ما
زالت تواصل قصفها وتجدد قصفها لعده اهداف
ولعده مناطق في لا سما المناطق الشرقيه
لقطاع غزه اذا بدانا من رفح والمناطق
الشرقيه لرفح تشهد اليوم عمليات اطلاق
قذائف من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه ايضا يسمع
ما بين الفينه والاخرى اصوات اشتباكات على
ما يبدو وانها ناجمه عن اشتباك عناصر
المقاومه الفلسطينيه مع قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي توغلت لعده امتار داخل
قطاع غزه من المناطق الشرقيه لرفح وقصفت
هذه المناطق بعده قذائف من المدفعيه
والاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه المتمركزه
على الحدود الشرقيه ايضا يسمع ما بين
الفينه والاخرى اصوات اطلاق نار من
الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه في تلك
المناطق الشرقيه لمدينه رفح ايضا جنوب
قطاع غزه في خانيونس بالتحديد تعرضت مدينه
خانيونس الى غاره قبل قليل استهدفت على ما
يبدو مجموعه من المواطنين الفلسطينيين
الذين كانوا يتواجدون في تلك المنطقه
ونقلت اعداد من الاصابات الى مستشفى ناصر
بالاضافه الى ان المناطق الشرقيه لمدينه
خانيونس عبسان والقرار وخزاعه وبن سيلا
ومعا والزن وهذه المناطق تتعرض الى قصف
عنيف بشكل لحظي وبشكل يومي من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه وبالتالي تواصل المدفعيه
قصفها لهذه الاهداف ولهذ هذه المناطق وجل
ما يتم ما يتم استهدافه هي منازل مدنيه
فلسطينيه في تلك المناطق وسط قطاع غزه
ايضا شهد قصف عنيف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه لا سما شرق مخيم المغازي وشرق
مخيم البريش شرق دير
البلح وهذه المناطق تتعرض الى قصف من
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه بشكل مكثف خلال هذه
اللحظات وايضا منذ صباح هذا اليوم تتعرض
هذه المناطق الى قصف وايضا اطلاق نار من
قبل القوات الاسرائيليه المتمركزه على
الحدود الشرقيه ايضا شنت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه غاره على مخيم المغازي وايضا
غاره على مخيم البريج وكذلك هذه الغارات
استهدفت اراض زراعيه في تلك المناطق ربما
الاحداث الاكثر عنفا واكثر كثافه هي تلك
التي تشهدها مدينه غزه والان القصف المكثف
الذي يشهده مخيم جباليا وايضا بلده جباليا
وهذه المناطق تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من
المدفع من الطائرات هناك اشتباكات عنيفه
ما بين العناصر المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي ما زالت متوغلا
في اكثر من محور من هذه المحاور في مدينه
غزه وشمال القطاع حي الشيخ رضوان ايضا
يشهد قصف من قبل المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
المدفعيه والاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
اعادت التموضع والتمركز في اكثر من محور
بالقرب وفي محيط حي الشيخ رضوان وتقصف ما
بين الفينه والاخرى المواطنين الفلسطينيين
الذين ما زالوا في تلك
المناطق ايضا المناطق الغربيه لمدينه غزه
تتعرض الى قصف من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
كانت الدبابات الاسرائيليه قد انسحبت من
هذه المناطق وعادت وطلبت من الناس والسكان
لا سما من المناطق الشرقيه التوجه الى هذه
المناطق وبعد ذلك توغلت في تلك المناطق
اعتقلت من اعتقلت وتقصف الان في تلك
المناطق وهناك اعداد من الشهداء والجرحى
يصلون يوميا الى المستشفيات من جراء
استمرار عمليات القصف الاسرائيلي لهذه
المناطق الاصعب من كل ذلك ان سيارات
الاسعاف سيارات الدفاع المدني لا تستطيع
التحرك في مدينه غزه وفي شمال القطاع
بحريه بعض المناطق حتى ممنوع الوصول اليها
لا سما في ظل الاستهداف المباشر
والاستهداف المتكرر لهذه المناطق وايضا
استهداف الجيش الاسرائيلي والطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه للبنى التحتيه
للشوارع وبالتالي لا تستطيع السيارات
الوصول الى الاماكن بسهوله ان استطاعت
اصلا التحرك في تلك المناطق في ظل استمرار
القصف الاسرائيلي بلديه غزه اليوم تعلن عن
انهيار خدماتها بشكل تام وهذا بالتاكيد
انذار ومؤشر على كارثيه الاوضاع لا سما
بعد اكثر من 78 يوما من الحرب الاسرائيليه
كانت هذه البلديه مستمره في عملها لكن بكل
تاكيد هي لا لا تعمل بشكل طبيعي امدادات
المياه امدادات الصرف الصحي ال عمليات جمع
القمامه والكثير من الاحتياجات والخدمات
التي تقدمها البلديه الان هي لن تستطيع
تقديم بسبب استمرار هذا العدوان
واستهدافها استهداف البلديه المباشر
واستهداف مقراتها في اكثر من مكان وفي
اكثر من منطقه في مدينه غزه لا سما مقرها
الاساسي في ساحه في منطقه الساحه في
البلده القديمه في مدينه غزه بالتالي
القصف الاسرائيلي يعطل هذه الخدمات والان
الناس سيبقون بدون اي ان نوع من انواع
المياه وحتى ان كانت غير صالحه للشرب فهم
لا يستطيعون توفير لا مياه صالحه ولا مياه
مياه غير صالحه بالاضافه الى شح المواد
التموينيه والمواد الاساسيه في مدينه غزه
وفي شمال القطاع وبالكاد يستطيع الناس
توفير بعض الاحتياجات لا سما في ظل منع
الجيش الاسرائيلي وصول المساعدات الى
مدينه غزه وشمال القطاع الان يضاف الى كل
هذه الاحداث وكل هذه الاوضاع الاحوال
الجويه السيئه هذه الرياح الشديده التي
تعصب بقطاع غزه وبالتالي الناس النازحون
في الخيام في مستشفيات مدينه غزه في
مستشفيات شمال القطاع وفي الشوارع وحتى في
المناطق التي دمرت نصبوا خياما هناك
بالاضافه الى كل قطاع غزه الناس النازحه
نصبت خياما في المستشفيات في مراكز الاواء
في المدارس اغلبها الان تطاير بفعل هذه
الرياح الشديده وهطول الامطار يغرقها بكل
تاكيد ويزيد من صعوبه الاوضاع لدى هؤلاء
النازحين